وفي الخبر العاجل نقلا عن مراسل الجزيره
13 شهيدا سقطوا في القصف الاسرائيلي
المتواصل على مدينه غزه منذ فجر اليوم
ينضم الينا من رفح الدكتور صهيب الكحلوت
مدير مستشفى الكويت في رفح دكتور اعداد
كبيره من الشهداء والجرحى جراء تصعيد
الحمله العسكريه الاسرائيليه في خانيونس
ما الذي يصل الى مستشفى الكويت حيث انت
حياكم الله اخي الكريم عشر ايام بعد المئه
مرت على اهل غزه ولا زال العدوان الصهيوني
مستمرا على اهلنا في قطاع غزه مرت المئ
يوم وما يزيد كانها 100 عام ولم نكن نتوقع
ان نصل الى هذا اليوم لم نكن نتوقع ان
يستمر الصمت العربي بكل وقاحه وكل بجاحه
امام دمائنا وامام اشلاء الاطفال والنساء
التي تنتهك حرماتهم كل يوم لم نكن نتوقع
ان يستمر صمت المجتمع الدولي والعرب
والاسلام بهذه الوقاحه العدو الصهيوني
استباح دمائنا في كل مكان العدو الصهيوني
استمر في اختراق كل القوانين الدوليه
والاعراف الانسانيه والشرائع السماويه
اليوم ما نعانيه اليوم في غزه كارثه
انسانيه بكل ما تعنيه الكلمه كذب من قال
ان الناس لا يموتون جوعا من قال ان الناس
لا يموتون جوعا فليات الى غزه وليرى ان
الناس هنا يموتون جوعا وبردا ويموتون
نتيجه الاهمال الطبي وعدم توفر الخدمات
الطبيه في ظل خروج المنظومه الصحيه عن
الخدمه اليوم نقول ان مستشفياتنا اليوم
اصبحت مقابر جماعيه رغم قله عددها اليوم
اخي الكريم مستشفياتنا تعاني نقصا حادا في
امكانياتها اليوم نقول اذا كان هناك مئات
المرضى الذين يموتون كل يوم من القصف
فهناك اليوم الاف المرضى الذين يموتون في
بيوتهم نتيجه عدم توفر الدواء ما يمارسه
الاحتلال الصهيوني اليوم من قطع لامدادات
الغذاء والماء والدواء والكهرباء عن غزه
امام صمت المجتمع الدولي والعربي
والاسلامي انما هو عار على كل على كل مسلم
عار على امه المليارين ان تنظر اليوم الى
غزه انا لا اعرف اذا لم تحركهم دمائنا
واشلاء انا واشلاء الاطفال الذين ترونها
بام اعينكم واصبحتم تتحدثون اليوم عن غزه
بلغه الارقام لم تعد لغه الارقام تجدي
نفعا معكم اليوم اخي الكريم نحن اليوم في
مستشفياتنا في مستشفى الكويت التخصصي في
محافظه رفح هذا المستشفى بسيط الامكانيات
في محافظه رفح التي يبلغ عدد سكانها اقل
من 300000 نسمه اصبح بفضل الاحتلال
الصهيوني الذي اجبر السكان واجبر سكان
الشمال من النزوح الاجباري والتهجير
القصري من الشمال الى الجنوب اصب عدد سكان
رفح اليوم مليون ونصف نسمه في ظل عدم وجود
بنيه تحتيه في ظل عدم وجود اسره عنايه
مركزه لا يوجد حتى تصوير طبقي لا يوجد كل
التخصصات طبيه غير متوفره ابسط الادويه لم
تعد متوفره ا الامراض المزمنه لاننا لاننا
نلحظ نشاطا لسيارات الاسعاف في في الخلفيه
نريد ان نعلم لو
سمحت ما القدره الاستيعابيه لمستشفى
الكويت وما الذي يصل اليكم من عدد الجرحى
والشهداء وامكانيه اسعاف الجرحه في هذه
الظروف هم حصيله طائرات الكواد كابتر اخي
الكريم التي الان استهدفت الامنين في
المواصي ما يصلنا الان هم حصيله طائرات
الكواد كابتر التي تستهدف المواطنين في في
قيام النازحين العدو الصهيوني
يمارس انتهاكه لكل القوانين الدوليه هو من
امن النازحين الى الشمال الى الجنوب هو من
قصفهم في الطريق هوان يقصف في مناطق امنه
ادعى امنه في محافظه رفح والان يقصف
الامنين في خيامهم في منطقه المواصل التي
ادعى الاحتلال الصوني انها اكثر منطقه
اكثر المناطق امنا اخي الكريم مستشفياتنا
الان والله نبكي قهرا والله العظيم وهي
اخونا الاستاذ هشام زقوت الان راى بام
عينه الذك الاطباء يبكون قهرا وعجزا امام
المرضى والحالات الكثيره التي لا نستطيع
ان نق نقدم لها ابسط الامكانيات اليوم
اليوم نبكي قهرا وعجزا لكن باذن الله
تعالى لا خيار امامنا اما ان ننتصر او
نموت لا خيار امامنا سوى الصمود باذن الله
تعالى لا خيار امامنا ان نخذل مرضانا بعد
ان خذلنا كل العالم العربي والاسلامي
والمجتمع الدولي اليوم مستشفياتنا يا اخي
الكريم لا يوجد فيها سعه سريريه ما يحدث
الان في مستشفى ناصر وخروجه التدريجي عن
الخدمه اليوم هو كارثه فوق الكارثه التي
نعانيها انا لا اعلم اين سنضع المرضى من
منذ الصباح ونحن نحاول التواصل مع
المنظمات الدوليه ومع بعض المنظمات
والمستشفيات لمحاوله استيعاب المرضى حتى
المستشفيات الميدانيه غير متوفره حتى
الوفود الطبيه القادمه الان ليس لها مكان
لتذهب اليه مستشفياتنا الان متوقفه عن
الخدمه ما نقدمه هو خدمه الطوارئ البسيطه
والمرضى يموتون من ابسط الامراض المرضى
يموتون من نقص الاسره المتوفره لغسيل
الكلى المرضى يموتون نتيجه عدم توفر ادويه
السرطان المرضى اخي الكريم الان يموتون في
مستشفياتنا ونحن نقف قهرا وعزا ولن نسامح
ولن نعذر كل من يتخلى عن غزه دكتور
ص وتعودون الى بيوتكم اليوم وكان شيئا لم
يكن مره اخرى الريم زلنا ننادي لكم لن
نسامحكم في دمائنا ولن نسامحكم في دماء
اطفالنا الكتور صهيب الهمص مدير مستشفى
الكويت في رفح شكرا لكذ